haha the Joe Rogan experience yeah we're
in a we're in a strange strange moment
in history yeah it's strange but it's an
opportunity as really is something you
got to look at like you said something
to me when I asked you last week how
you're doing you said you just you're
just trying to accept and I think that's
the key if you can accept it then you
can be proactive about it you can be
creative about it you can just take
whatever life force you have and and you
know look at what what what are the
possibilities here don't have any
expectations that get shattered by
reality accept what it is what it is is
a new thing you know stay alive be nice
to each other and and do your best and
try to get through this and hopefully at
the other end when science and medicine
has gotten a handle on this hopefully we
can go back to normal life they'll be
wonderful but right now we can't so it
is what it is if you just want to run
around screaming and hollering and
freaking out about it and it's not good
what what makes me more concerned than
anything is what is life gonna be like
once the economy rolls back again how
many people gonna be out of work how
many business is gonna be shuttered how
many you know how [ __ ] up is it gonna
be that gives me the most fear of the
unknown because I know that a certain
amount of people are gonna get sick and
a certain large percentage are gonna get
better and unfortunately some people are
gonna die and all that's awful but I
kind of see that that that makes sense
in my mind I kind of see a disease I see
people that all make sense what doesn't
make sense is an economy that stops and
then restarts again I've never seen that
yeah so for that I'm like what is that
like and there's no model to base it on
because our economy today is so much
different than it was you know even ten
years ago the International economy it
is it's a it's a digital economy there's
so much of it that we don't we don't
know how it's gonna how it's gonna play
out
yeah and I know that a lot more people
are gonna stop going to work I think
that businesses are saying oh we don't
need offices for a hundred percent of
our people and parking spots no we'll
just have 50 percent of the people work
from
like we just did for the last three
months that worked that would be very
cost-effective for people that don't
want to have gigantic offices and then
also how free how much freedom it is if
you can work from home yep I mean for a
lot of people if that's possible that
would definitely be preferable hell yeah
and productivity I can tell you from
writing on TV shows over the years
there's been some that I've written from
home you know where I'm like a
consultant that's just handing him its I
do so much more work when I have to
actually hand it in through an email
than when I'm sitting in a writers room
with 12 other people throwing out a line
once an hour I'll I'm eating [ __ ]
sushi I mean I work my ass off when I'm
home because I got a I got to justify it
yes that's a good point that's a good
point you're accountable yeah I mean I
think a good thing to do right now would
be to think about that in terms of
creation of material one thing I've been
guilty of over the last month I haven't
written jack [ __ ] I'm gonna have a
couple ideas I wrote down but I really
have been writing when I haven't been
doing stand-up and I decided what I
wanted to do is I wanted to know what my
take on this is and I felt like the best
way I could figure out what my take on
it is is just have a natural take on it
mhm
like actually go through this and and
find out what it is first how long it's
gonna last and what what are you what
are your thoughts on this and at the
beginning I didn't know what my thoughts
on it were because my thoughts on it
were stay safe
make sure family stays safe friends stay
safe you know do whatever you're
supposed to do and and let's find out
how long it's gonna take what are the
experts say talk to some experts what's
the prognosis look like it keeps getting
pushed back now it's June now they're
saying June things are gonna restart on
June like [ __ ] what is that like what
does that like for people that are
checked to check three months yeah
April May June right when when does it
when does it go back three months from
now and it's already been a month whoa
you know what went what day June what if
June 14 you've got more cases then what
do we do when do we do we ever say [ __ ]
it let's just go back to work what is
that like hmm what kind of drunken Wild
West party
oh yeah gonna be when people go back to
work and start going back to bars and
yeah they forgot how to be out at a bar
at a nightclub mm-hmm how many people
gonna be pregnant when this this all
goes back there's gonna be a giant up
nine months from now oh yeah I didn't
think of that they're [ __ ] and
they're scared and they're shooting
those those fear-based loads yep which
are heavy dude we're running out of
condoms I was just reading the paper
that's there like who they produce all
the condoms in Malaysia so I think it's
in Malaysia and [ __ ] their shuttered
the factory shattered we need to make
[ __ ] here but we need to make [ __ ] in a
way that doesn't destroy the environment
and one of the ways they are able to
make [ __ ] in other countries is they
don't have the same regulations
environmental regulations as they do
here that's always been the big problem
with shipping stuff overseas they also
don't have the same regulations like
when the Foxconn scandal came out and
they found out there was Nets around the
building to keep people from jumping try
the building where they make iPhones
yeah like what yeah we gotta make them
here and we got to figure out a way
where we make them well we have a the
person who makes them makes good living
you know the back of the old days when
they used to have like great cars that
were made in Detroit they were all made
in Detroit in Detroit was a huge city
now Detroit was one of the richest
cities in the country yeah it was huge
now it's a disaster because everything
got shipped overseas or everything got
shipped to you know different places
well they got to figure out you know the
union's because the unions are a great
theory and they have worked well in a
lot of ways but they also have huge
problems and they've there's got to be a
way to get unions back in place that can
guarantee people health coverage and
retirement without making the cost of
doing business so high that it hurts the
industry I don't know jack [ __ ] about
finances so I don't know whether or not
I should even comment on that but it
would be nice if everybody worked it out
yeah it would be nice if everybody
figured out how to make [ __ ] in America
where we don't have to worry about
things going down and let's let's learn
from this to learn from this and start
making medicine over here why is all the
medicine made
in China what right how much what it's
crazy
yeah we make a lot of [ __ ] but we need
to balance out we need to balance out
for some sort of apocalyptic event we
got to be prepared well this is like you
know we're streamlining right now we're
realizing what's necessary and what's
luxury and we're getting we're keeping
it simple and then we're gonna come out
of it having a better gauge of what each
of us needs or individually in the
second term we go to war with Iran China
backs Iran whoa
things get crazy no one has any money
50% are out of work militaries in the
streets
yeah kovat 21 comes out yeah kills 40%
of the population still no ventilators
right that's possible too yeah yeah
there's a lot of Possible's out there
that was the thing that we wish we were
shipping stuff overseas they just just
read something today that like we were
sending metal medical equipment to other
countries we were do you read anything
about that it was when the ship broke
down in China we shipped a bunch of our
stuff there to help them without then
replenishing what we shipped over okay
oh we got stupid I think that's what I
think I also read something about
Thailand that we would that we were in
the Pratt we were actually shipping
stuff to Thailand right now and then it
was some kind of mix-up and the
government's apologizing about it now
[Applause]